um how's the father life treating you
man oh usually you got your kid with you
I just had some I got a daughter but my
kids they like especially my son he
thinks like well my daughter's too small
but my son
how old is he he's about to be
kindergarten damn he's just yeah he just
graduated today do you let your kid
because my son is eight well he's nine
now
and he'd be on that YouTube man well my
son be on YouTube but he be looking at
like
weird games yeah like and you know they
be trying to send little subliminal
messages in between but you know so we
gotta take them off YouTube you think so
what what kind of supplemental messages
all type of weird [__] baby trying to
push a certainly who it's in there that
ain't mean really they trying to push
that lgbtq and nothing against it but
you know they be trying to push it a
little too hard kindergarten is crazy
did you see uh in Glendale there were
some protests did you see that yeah
there was a protest in Glendale and the
Armenians yeah you know they don't play
that [__]
I said [__] like getting right in front
of school
oh man them Armenians don't [__] around
bruh I think they don't even preach I
mean they don't even put sex ahead that
much in school like that so that's my
thing is like I think after like if you
want to do certain [__] and teach people
about certain like stuff that's out make
sure y'all handle all the [__] that's
already out there I think like if you're
gonna do that don't do that before sex
ed yeah you wouldn't you wouldn't do
that prior to teaching a kid sex ed and
I don't think we learned sex ed until
maybe like seventh or eighth grade maybe
yeah that's why I was just telling
someone like seven eighth grade that's
when they start really like coming to
school handing out the comment and [__]
100 man 100
um anything uh for you okay so for this
is the deluxe coming out this weekend
yeah on Friday but yeah it should be
coming up Friday at nine but it's really
12 in New York yo I noticed a lot of
people
the guy who does all your artwork is he
from Detroit no I think he's from like
London or something okay I've just
noticed I I've noticed everybody's using
him now yeah you kind of Set It Off me
and Draco because I was in um he did
that um I was in Detroit and someone
passed me I think it was uh that kid's
names jug Hardin passed me as his tape
or whatever
and I was like that's the same guy I'd
be doing all the Ralphie Draco [__] it's
the same [__] like he did that
thank you for using GTL yeah it's great
for that it was like
um who is there anybody else in La that
you uh that you've been uh checking out
that maybe we should be hip to because I
do feel like you got you here to the
street I mean I know you're you're I
think last time you told us about a
bunch of dope artists in stock like
the young [__] like remember I Brown's
Body [__] like
Jacy [__] R3 we talking crazy R3 from
uh where's he from San Bernardino yeah
yeah yeah you got some [__] going right
now no they do they got a lot of rappers
yeah it feels like all the random like
cities that are kind of shunned by the
big cities have been popping in in Cali
like Stockton is lit yeah no they is
I've been every time I look on this
right damn they stocked in [__]
I remember what I was saying that [__]
that's what made it even crazy ebk guys
and obviously uh shout out to uh
everybody stockings crazy Haiti babies
on [__] just got assigned to Jeezy
yeah